It's no secret: in the wealthiest countries,
fewer and fewer people want to have children.
The falling birth rate is practically a generalized
phenomenon throughout the developed world.
It seems clear that it is going to become
one of the greatest challenges in the very
near future: we are talking about countries
that are getting older and have fewer children.
In fact, most developed countries are already
well below the replacement rate.
That is, below the 2.1 children per woman
of childbearing age that would be needed to
at least keep the population stable, excluding
immigration, of course.
However, there is one specific case, a country
in which the average child per woman is not
only fewer than two children per woman, but
less than one!
We are talking about the country with the
lowest birth rate in the world.
And yes, as you may have already guessed,
if only by the thumbnail and the title of
this video, I'm talking about South Korea.
Check it out.
Specifically, we are talking about a fertility
rate of only 0.78 children per woman in 2022.
A level so low that we could almost say that
having children in South Korea has become
an anomaly.
And, take note, because in Seoul this rate
is even worse, wait for it, we are talking
about only 0.59 children per woman.
Down to almost a quarter of the replacement
rate.
In other words, in this case, it is not that
South Korea is going through a demographic
winter, it is that we are practically facing
the chronicle of an extinction foretold.
Despite being one of the richest and most
advanced countries in the world, South Korea
is facing a colossal problem whose solution
is far from simple and which could cause a
demographic catastrophe in this country as
never seen before.
A demographic catastrophe and, if things do
not change, perhaps an economic one as well.
Even with the strong robotization of industry,
if things continue as they are, it is possible
that in a short time there will not be enough
workers to keep the economy going: its factories,
its stores, its schools and businesses of
all kinds.
And no, we are not exaggerating.
We're not exaggerating at all.
Take a look at this graph:
Do you realize what this means?
What you are looking at is South Korea's population
projection over the next few decades.
As you can see, as of today the Land of Morning
Calm may have already reached its historical
maximum population.
From now on its population will not only be
much older, but it will also begin to decrease.
And don't think it will do so slowly.
In the next 40 years this country will lose
more than 12 million inhabitants, that is,
25% of its entire population.
In demographic terms, that's a huge drop in
population.
And that's not all.
By the end of the century, if the current
trend continues, South Korea's population
is expected to shrink to less than half.
From today’s almost 52 million inhabitants
to just over 20 million.
There is no other country in the world with
such a poor outlook.
We are talking about a scenario in which not
only South Koreans may end up disappearing,
but a lot of wealth could be destroyed in
the process meaning that those remaining will
face enormous hardship.
Think about it, if the forecasts come true,
many of the children being born today will
see their country with half the population
when they retire, with all that implies:
More social spending, less savings, less consumption,
and so on and so forth.
And, keep in mind, we are not talking about
a vague hypothesis, but about a process that
has already begun.
After years with an absolutely plummeting
birth rate, there are already many cases in
the country of primary schools, obstetric
and pediatric hospitals and services that
are having to close.
Now, many of you may be wondering at this
point...
Why on earth is this happening in a country
where the economy is supposedly booming and
people are not lacking anything?
What exactly are the reasons why South Koreans
no longer want to have children?
What is the government doing to reverse this
situation?
Does it have a solution?
Well, in this video we are going to answer
these and more questions, so...
Pay attention, because this is the story of
the country that is running towards its own
extinction.
(THE FOUR 'NOES')
As you can imagine, a disaster like the one
we are describing is not something that just
happens.
There are reasons, and they are neither few
nor easy to explain.
But here on VisualPolitik we are going to
try to tell you about it in the most summarized
way possible.
You see, the easiest thing to do would be
to blame it on low wages, hyper-competitiveness
in South Korea, or that women prefer to focus
on their careers rather than put them at risk
to have children.
But...
No, although these factors are partly to blame,
they do not explain why South Korea is the
country with the lowest birth rate in the
world.
After all, these factors apply elsewhere as
well.
So, what on earth has caused the problem in
South Korea to reach such a magnitude?
Well, I can tell you in advance that some
things will shock you a lot.
On the one hand, South Korean society is perhaps
one of the most conservative and traditional
of all developed countries.
And okay, yes, I know what you are thinking,
but [host], conservative societies usually
have an advantage when it comes to birth rates,
don't they?
Well, no, not always.
One of the problems they have in the Land
of the Morning Calm is their extremely puritanical
or traditional way of understanding motherhood
and family models.
In fact, there is virtually only one family
model: the one formally composed between a
woman and a man.
And then the children, of course.
Anything outside this framework is effectively
left out of the system, and South Korean society
loses a lot of opportunities to solve, or
at least mitigate, its major childlessness
problem.
But as I know that what I have said may be
surprising and that some of you are probably
shocked, we are going to give you data and
concrete examples...
For example, in South Korea, only 2.9 percent
of babies born in 2021 were born out of wedlock,
while the OECD average is, – wait for it
– FORTY percent, 16 times higher.
Nearly forty percent of children in South
Korea are simply not born.
In other words, in South Korean society it’s
inconceivable to have children without a traditional
marriage.
Being married is a prerequisite for having
children.
And no, it is not that they are religiously
or socially very different or that they have
more appetite for marriage, which I already
told you they do not.
It is a matter, above all a cultural one.
In the case of single mothers, for example,
many face the judgment of a society in which
honor and what people will say still carry
a lot of weight.
And what can I say?
In South Korea, having a child out of wedlock
is frowned upon.
And let's not even talk about same-sex families.
In general, all these things are considered
bad for children in this country.
And, while children in the rest of the developed
world don’t appear to be turning out so
badly, in this video we are not going to debate
family structures, what we care about here
is the impact this rigid attitude has on birth
rates.
The fact is that all this cultural pressure
forces women to make a choice: to look for
a husband at all costs in order to have children,
or to forego motherhood and focus on themselves
and their professional careers.
And yes, that's exactly what many women are
doing, choosing this second option.
We'll tell you why in more detail later.
But the fact is that in the end, fewer and
fewer women are willing to have children,
which, logically, contributes to the fact
that the birth rate is at rock bottom.
But, wait a minute because it's not all bad
news.
Fortunately, society is also changing and
little by little, more and more people are
accepting motherhood outside of traditional
marriage.
For example, in the 10 years between 2012
and 2022, acceptance of single motherhood
has grown by more than 12 points, from just
over 22% to nearly 35% of respondents.
Of course, public institutions are still slower
at making progress.
For example, the South Korean Mother and Child
Health Act's definition of sub-fertility explicitly
refers to a "married couple".
That is, there is no other possibility for
receiving fertility treatment support.
One way or another, the system excludes single
women from access to fertility or in vitro
fertilization treatments.
What's more, the South Korean Bioethics and
Safety Act says that anyone seeking to perform
IVF treatment must have the consent of their
partner.
In other words, it is taken for granted that
these treatments are exclusively for couples,
which means that in South Korea it is, in
practice, impossible for a woman alone to
have access to them.
And not only that, apart from what the law
itself says, the South Korean Church is also
fervently opposed to these techniques for
unmarried women.
Keep in mind we are talking about a country
where the relationship between politicians
and religious congregations is usually very
close.
And VisualPolitik viewers, all this becomes
even more important if we take into account
another problem that young South Korean women
today do not want to deal with.
Basically the traditional roles that still
exist in South Korean society regarding motherhood
and marriage.
You could say that the professional and personal
ambitions of young women in this country have
changed much faster than the perception of
their role in society.
For example, it is very, very common in South
Korea for men to leave the burden of raising
children to women, even if the woman works.
In South Korea, children are strictly women's
business...
And logically, this is not easy to reconcile
with modern life and the legitimate personal
and professional aspirations of hundreds and
thousands, millions of women.
It's something we've told you many times on
VisualPolitik: narratives count.
And, no, we are not talking about "hetero-patriarchy"
or anything like that, but about social roles
that in the vast majority of the West have
already been overcome, but the same has not
happened in South Korea, nor in Asia in general.
And then, of course, there is also the issue
of salaries, the desire for careers and extremely
expensive housing, something we have talked
about in previous videos.
Well, the fact is that the sum of all these
reasons has led more and more young women
to feel that marriage and motherhood are an
unnecessary burden, or rather a problem that
they have no desire to face.
Do you want an eye-popping fact?
According to a 2020 survey, 42.5% of South
Koreans in their thirties were not married,
13 points higher than in 2010.
(Romance booming in South Korea, but marriage
no longer the end game – The Japan Times)
In fact, of all households in South Korea,
as many as four out of 10 are single-person
households, and 2022 saw the lowest number
of marriages since 1970, with fewer than 192,000.
In South Korea, young women are less and less
willing to get married and take on all that
this entails in the culture and society of
this country.
And you have already seen that without marriage
there are no children either, or at least
there are far fewer of them.
What’s more, divorce is also a taboo in
Korean society.
Despite being legal, many women who divorce
face some form of discrimination, although
it is becoming more socially accepted thanks
to contemporary Korean TV series and films.
This means that a woman is acutely aware that,
if she gets married, she could have a hard
time after divorce if things go wrong.
And this, of course, makes many of them even
more hesitant to get married nowadays.
But there's more.
As much as this may surprise you, there is
even a women's movement known as the four
no's: no dating, no sex with men, no marriage
and no children.
The traditional family is becoming less and
less popular among young people in this country.
And as you can see, the way things are set
up has consequences.
But, at this point and now that you know what
the main causes of this demographic debacle
are, many of you may be asking yourselves
a question: what on earth is the government
doing to try to solve this situation?
Can it do anything?
Well, the truth is that yes, they have done
and continue to do things.
But you could say that... basically, it seems
as if they were desperately trying to do things
blindly.
Do you want to hear what is probably the funniest
part of this whole story?
Well, pay close attention.
(KILLING FLIES WITH CANNONS)
Let me ask you a question, what if I told
you that South Korea has squandered $200 billion
over the last 16 years on policies to encourage
birth rates, and yet they have achieved absolutely
nothing at all?
$200 billion later the number of births is
at historic lows.
[Which, by the way, is a warning to all those
politicians who think that this matter can
be solved with a checkbook].
It turns out, the South Korean State has squandered
some $12.5 billion dollars every year on birthrate
management policies.
This is more or less the budget that a country
like Spain allocates to defense annually.
And as you can see, the result has been...
zilch.
Could it be that South Korea is the perfect
example of how the birth rate cannot be encouraged
with public money?
Well, maybe yes, maybe we are facing the wildest
example we can see.
But that’s not the worst of it, the worst
is that the government continues to opt for
this path despite admitting that it does not
work.
(31 August 2022: Korea to Triple Baby Payments
After It Smashes Own Record for World's Lowest
Fertility Rate – Bloomberg)
To give you an idea, President Yoon has announced
that he would triple the baby check already
in place for the first two years of a newborn's
life.
This is an increase from the 300,000 won set
by former President Moon Jae-in [Pron Moon
Tsae-een] to one million won, which is slightly
more than $750 per month.
And let's not fool ourselves, the result will
probably not change anything.
In rich countries like South Korea, having
or not having children has more to do with
social and cultural factors and less to do
with economic problems.
("If the environment is right and when people
feel they are protected and encouraged to
have children, they will have babies even
if they are told not to.
Cash incentives alone can't really make much
progress in boosting child births."
– Chung Ick-joong, social welfare professor
at Ewha Womans University)
Of course, the truth is that even this measure
– probably as useless as the previous one
– is better than other crazy ideas that
South Korean politicians have come up with
to deal with this problem.
Some of them are so crazy that anyone would
think that they are desperate, just grasping
at straws.
You don't believe us?
Think we're exaggerating?
Well, take note.
Some time ago, for example, a dozen legislators
put forward a proposal to flood the country
with foreign nannies paid below minimum wage.
In fact, the proposal included waiving the
minimum wage for foreign nannies.
This is something that has already been done
in countries such as Singapore under the excuse
that conditions are still much better than
in their home countries.
Nevertheless, it is something that raised
a lot of criticism in South Korea.
Then there was also a proposal to exempt men
who have three or more children before the
age of 30 from compulsory military service.
The problem is that men are the only ones
who are obliged to do military service and,
what can I tell you?
No matter how many men are willing to get
rid of the annoying military service in this
way, if there are no women willing to have
children, it’s a useless measure.
But wait a minute because now comes the really
good part.
The two things I’m about to tell you now
have come true, this is not a joke.
Check it out.
(31 December 2016: South Korea pulls website
mapping women of prime age to have children.
South Korea has closed a government website
showing the number of women aged between 15
and 49 - of childbearing age - by city district
and region after a public outcry.
[Users could look up how many women between
those ages resided in their neighbourhood
for the past 10 years.
– The Guardian)
It's like a kind of Farmer Wants a Wife except
strictly online and where the women have no
idea they’ve been selected for the show
and no one even asked them if they wanted
to get married.
Not to worry though, it’s promoted by the
government...
Don't you think it's brilliant?....
Anyway.
Well, if that has caught your attention, you
ain't seen nothing yet.
In South Korea there are local governments
that have been subsidizing the [HOST: air
quotes] "purchase" of foreign wives.
Yes, yes, that’s what I said.
(19 February 2019: South Korea's local subsidies
encourage foreign 'bride buying'; brides from
Uzbekistan 'most expensive'
More than 35 municipal governments [...] have
implemented by-laws providing marriage subsidies
to local men who tie the knot with foreign
brides – The Straits Times)
We are talking about a whole ‘mail order
bride’ industry that has been around for
a few years now in Korea.
In fact, it seems to have really taken off.
Even in Seoul itself there are numerous establishments,
businesses, where you can go, choose a woman
from a catalog and then, after paying a certain
fee, these companies arrange for these women
to fly to South Korea to marry you.
Obviously, not in a forced way...
But even so, it's crazy.
South Korea is, along with Taiwan, the Asian
country where this practice is most common.
For some, this is a clear example of human
trafficking, but for others it is nothing
more than an intermediation like any other.
In fact, this type of activity has a name:
they are called marriage brokers.
And take note, there are almost 400 of them
throughout the country.
And I don't know, what do you want me to say?
Moral considerations aside, perhaps the fact
that there are public administrations subsidizing
these operations with up to almost $10,000
dollars crosses all lines.
And yes, that is exactly what some municipalities
do.
The result?
You can see it perfectly in this graph.
Be that as it may, as you have seen, South
Korea has a birth rate problem so severe that
it may put the country itself on the road
to its own extinction.
A problem that, far from improving, is only
getting worse.
More and more women are rejecting motherhood
and marriage.
And that in a society and under institutions
that are still unable to accept other types
of motherhood or familial roles and adapt
public policies is a serious problem.
But, at this point, it's your turn.
Do you think South Korea could reverse its
enormous demographic problem with other kinds
of public policies?
Has the old model of believing that to have
children you just need to give away more and
more money failed?
What do you think of the proposals and policies
that are being promoted in South Korea to
get more children born?
Leave us your opinion below, in the comments.
And remember, if you liked this video don't
forget to like it, subscribe to our channel
and hit the little bell so you don't miss
any news coming soon.
Oh, and very important, if you want to help
us to keep growing and improving, you can
join our community in Patreon to receive exclusive
content.
I’ll leave you the link in the description.
Once again, thank you very much for being
there.
All the best and see you next time.